good afternoon everyone and welcome
please be seated
it's great to see everyone on this very
sunny and warm New York day be thankful
those of you who don't have to wear a
polyester black robe when it's 92
degrees out but it's great to see you my
name is Kevin Shallenberger i'm the dean
of students and i had the pleasure of
working with these amazing talented
undergraduate students from columbia
college and columbia engineering
so we're here today to celebrate the
class of 2014 and our new transfers and
combine plans students into the Columbia
community so on behalf of president
Bollinger provo steel vice president
Dirk's Dean moody Adams Dean Penn amaura
and Daniel chavela we welcome you to
convocation 2010 to help honor our new
students and families as they embark on
this exciting journey we are joined
today by members of our alumni network
Columbia's distinguished faculty staff
and administrators and current student
leaders their support is a hallmark of
the Columbia experience which is defined
not only by the learning that takes
place in the classroom and laboratories
but also by the community that thrives
both here on campus and around the world
to new students today marks for you the
induction into this community you will
soon see for yourself that it is a close
knit one where ideas are exchanged often
and lively debate transit traditions
passed on from generation to generation
diversity of all kinds valued and
intellectual and co-curricular inquiry
encouraged and though we are many in
number share traditions uniquely
Colombian experiences and common
principles connect us all this vibrant
and exciting community is one in which
each of you now belongs and on behalf of
the entire Columbia community and
Columbia family we welcome you
I love our orientation leaders and our
a's so this is one of many occasions we
in the Division of Student Affairs look
forward to we prepare and great earnest
for your arrival to our new students in
the fervor that will soon overwhelm the
campus in the next few days you'll take
part in academic advising sessions
community forums resin hall meetings
runs in Riverside Park and adventures in
new york city there are many other
numerous activities that are in your
orientation booklet you will be guided
in this exploration by current students
capably navigating you has crew chiefs
orientation leaders resident advisors
and community advisors they will help
you a quaint acquaint you with one
another columbia and the city you now
call home they have made an
extraordinary commitment of energy and
time to ensure the next week leaves you
with great and lasting memories of your
first few days here at Columbia so
please help me and join me in thanking
these very dedicated and enthusiastic
student leaders
new students we know that each of you
will follow in their footsteps
contributing in your own way to this
thriving and vibrant community here in
Morningside Heights this is one of the
reasons we select at you and I know one
of the many reasons you selected us and
I'm glad you did indeed we have a lot to
be proud of here at Columbia but
certainly our student body is at the top
of the list our students make the
Columbia experience uniquely so and a
Columbia education one of the best in
the world they are talented curious
passionate their past experiences are
wide-ranging but their hopes and dreams
for the future even more so they're our
origins are diverse and many represented
by the 159 flags both state and country
flags that you see before you and the
class of 2014 certainly contributes to
this diversity representing 48 states
and 52 countries and interest in 90
different majors and concentrations the
class of 2014 brings a variety of ideas
cultures perspectives and heritage from
which our entire community will benefit
in the coming days and weeks you'll get
to know much more about your fellow
Columbia students and many of them will
become your lifelong friends you will
learn from them and then from you so
don't underestimate this part of your
education yes today marks an exciting
journey of discovery learning and growth
but we all know that with this comes
some major changes you are moving here
some of you very far from home to begin
your college education at Columbia for a
short while at least you are leaving
familiar faces and routines it may not
always be easy but the best things in
life rarely are some of the greatest
learning moments no doubt will be some
the challenge
challenges you face both in and outside
the classroom but rest assured we are
here to support you every step of the
way this week you'll be introduced to
many advisors mentors and offices that
will support you take the initiative to
make those connections reach out to your
academic and personal advisors in the
center for student advising your
financial aid advisors we have community
development advisors working with our
clubs and organizations career advisors
and our Center for career advising we
have a whole team of people here to
assist you get to know your RA learn
about the other support services that
are available on campus and make good
use of the systems that we put in place
to help you succeed should you ever need
anything or be pointed in the right
direction please call on anyone in the
Division of Student Affairs to help you
and if I for a moment can just turn to
the parents and families and friends in
the audience we recognize that this is a
big change for you too but it my hope is
that you can leave here today confident
in the support services that we have in
place to help your students succeed
please know that they are in good hands
we look forward to working with you and
supporting your son and daughter and is
seeing you here for family weekend or
casual visits to campus and engaging
with you via office of Family and parent
programs you will soon learn if you
haven't already that families are also
an important part of our Columbia
community and lastly students above all
else enjoy your experience at Columbia
make it your own get involved with
campus life work hard contribute to the
larger community and by all means take
advantage of everything this world-class
institution and city have to offer you
we look forward to accompanying you in
this once in a lifetime journey you will
surely discover hidden talents explore
new passions uncover academic interests
and settle comfortably into your new
role has Colombians so again wonderful
seeing all of you and welcome
and now I'd like to introduce to you
Kevin Magus Columbia College of 2012 and
our coordinator for new Student
Orientation program born and raised in
New York State Kevin is studying French
although you are more than likely to see
him taking courses in anthropology and
Gender Studies on campus he's actively
involved in the Columbia queer alliance
and queer awareness month and the annual
all-ivy LGBT conference Kevin takes full
advantage of our location here in New
York City and likes attending Broadway
shows and the Metropolitan Opera this is
his second year working with n sock and
he has shared that one of his favorite
things about the experience is actually
move in day and seeing all the
excitement that's brought to campus from
our new students and Families so please
join me in welcoming Kevin
thank you it's an honor to be here today
welcoming you colombia's class of 2014
incoming transfer and combine plans
students your parents friends and
families into the community that I call
home it was just two years ago that i
SAT where many of you do today as new
students in columbia college or the fou
foundation school of engineering and
applied science I too was welcomed by a
fellow undergraduate and I wondered if I
would someday call this place which was
then so new to me home now standing
before you I have no doubt that long
after commencement day has passed and I
find myself living in another
neighborhood another borough another
city or even halfway around the world
I'll always call this place home but
what exactly does that mean
merriam-webster defines home is not only
a place of residence but a social unit a
familiar usual usual setting and a
congenial environment in college I think
home takes on two important meanings
first we seek an intellectual home where
we excuse me where we may explore
academic interest freely and without
consequence and where we're comfortable
expressing and sometimes defending what
we believe columbia is a place where
we're taught how to think instead of
what to think in a place where we gain
confidence in our convictions and our
understandings of the world we learn not
only in class but from our life
experiences outside the classroom we're
encouraged not to study just what will
be on the exam but also to ponder how
that knowledge affects our understanding
of the world in which we live most
importantly we're taught not only what
is required to earn our degree but how
to continue learning every day long
after low library and lerner hall or but
fond memories the Columbia community is
built on this philosophy of learning as
a lifelong pursuit learning is our means
of understanding the world and I've
found as I'm sure you will that this
principle is embodied in every member of
the university community its commitment
to this philosophy that unites
generations of Colombians before us and
leads them to call this place their
intellectual home and it's that same
commitment that will continue to
enlighten many generation
more second we seek a home where we may
find solace and comfort in a strong
community where we're supported as we
explore our passions leave our mark take
risks and discover who we are for each
of us this will mean two different
things and no two of our journeys will
look alike but we can all benefit from
words of advice from perhaps an unlikely
source I'm sure many of you remember
miss Frizzle from the Magic School Bus
as she would say it's time to take
chances make mistakes and get messy sure
it sounds scary at first and frankly
before i arrived at columbia I never
really stopped consider the true meaning
of those words but never before in our
lives have we've been given the chance
to make such an impactful and
life-changing decisions as we make
during these years what causes will we
take up what organizations will be join
who will we befriend and what will we do
after graduation for most of us the
opportunity to live so spontaneously
will vanish after we leave commencement
after we leave campus at commencement in
many ways the next few years are our
departure from the real world obviously
we have an objective for being here to
earn a degree but along our journey to
graduation each of our unique paths is
far more important than our common
destination so during orientation and
throughout your time here at Columbia
the best advice I can give is to be open
to new experiences and to take advantage
of unexpected opportunities because
they'll inevitably arise you'll be
supported in your adventure by one
another by your professors your advisors
your mentors and your family you'll
inevitably find your way and also come
to consider Columbia your home away from
home to demonstrate this point I'd like
to share a few personal experiences the
first occurred before I even considered
applying to Columbia the second before I
chose to attend and the most recent
after I arrived my first story begins
during my college search in my junior
year of high school as many of you
probably did I visited quite a few
schools a number of my top choices were
in the New York metro area but you might
be surprised to learn that our very own
Columbia was not on that list
it was only at the insistence of my
mother that I agreed to a campus visit
in an information session this is a
chance that I'm happy I took to be sure
the lesson here is be willing to take
risks give yourself permission to veer
from the straight path you've chosen and
abandon your preconceived notion of the
best route indeed some of the most
carefully laid plans are meant to be
broken the second story I want to share
occurred a little over a year later
after decision letters arrived I was
faced with the choice of which school to
attend i participated in days on campus
which is a fresh memory for many of you
I'm sure the weekend was so full of
activity that my memory of it is a blur
but one thing I remember distinctly is a
tour of Morningside Heights our
neighborhood though charming is less the
focal point of my memory than the
student who led the tour I quickly
forgot his name in his face but his
exuberance and enthusiasm for life for
learning and for Columbia itself made a
lasting impression on me with that my
mind was made up based on little more
than a hunch I would attend Columbia and
this turned out to be one of the best
decisions I've ever made the lesson here
be willing to make decisions that just
feel right be open to making a mistake
most of the time you can correct it
trust your convictions this leads me to
my final story which centers on my
friend Peter we met through mutual
friends soon after I arrived on campus
and I was immediately drawn to the
energy and the passion he displayed in
everything that he did we shared many
late nights in butler library and over a
number of months we became close friends
it was on one of those nights when we
were discussing his involvement with the
undergraduate recruitment committee and
days on campus that I realized he was
the tour guide who had welcomed me those
many months before the lesson here is
that even though you find yourself
surrounded today by unfamiliar faces you
might end up best friends with a
stranger to your left keep an open mind
about everyone and everything you
encounter here take a risk explore a new
interest enroll in a class outside your
major just because or invite the
acquaintance you run into every day for
a cup of coffee
as you embark on your journeys of
self-discovery today I have but one
request as you find your way to your
home in our community remember that it's
okay to take chances make mistakes and
get messy you never know where you're
going to end up thank you kevin is now
my pleasure to introduce to you mr.
Daniel chevelle Oh president of the
Columbia engineering alumni association
mr. Chuvalo graduated from columbia
engineering in 1975 with a bachelor's of
science and received his master's of
science the following year he is
currently the president of minerva
health technologies a company
specializing in personal health record
management software development his
company was named after Minerva the
Roman god goddess a wisdom in medicine
and the real name of colombia's alma
mater sculpture as an active columbia
engineering alumnus he has served as an
alumni representative committee regional
chairperson a civil engineering and
engineering mechanics industry advisory
committee member and a columbia
engineering alumni association board
member and board secretary this is his
second year as president of the Alumni
Association and as an ex officio member
of the board of visitors please join me
and welcome a very active alumni alumnus
mr. chevelle oh
so on behalf of over 60,000 members of
the columbia college and columbia
engineering alumni association's i would
like to welcome the class of 2014 and of
course i would like to also welcome all
of the proud parents and family members
my daughter just graduated from columbia
engineering last year so as a proud
alumnus and proud columbia parent I know
firsthand the special character of
Columbia and how wonderful and
exhilarating the Columbia experience
will be for you during the next four
years the excitement of New York City
the wide range of campus organizations
the diversity of the student body and
the stellar and abundant academic
opportunities are all beyond compare
creating an amazing and amazing and
enriching experience for those who live
in study here and hopefully you will
find as my daughter and I did that the
beautiful Columbia campus is a piece
peaceful urban oasis in the midst of a
dynamic but sometimes hectic City now
some of you may be wondering why an
alumnus was asked to speak to you today
considering that you haven't even
attended your first class yet well you
have just completed four years of hard
work in high school for the right to
become a Columbia student you will work
even harder that's right even harder for
the next four years for the right to
become an alumnus or alumna of Columbia
University now think about this for a
moment you will be a Columbia student
for about four years but you will be a
Columbia's Columbia alum for the rest of
your life
in fact I am proud to say that this year
I am celebrating 35 years as a Columbia
alumnus but I am Not sure I would have
even been admitted if I had to compete
with the quality of today's applicants
especially students like you so I still
carry my original Columbia ID card to
prove that I was once a student here I
also keep it to prove that i once had
hair and lots of it more importantly it
really is a great reminder of all of my
wonderful memories as a student as an
active alumnus and now even as a
Columbia parent when you graduate I'm
sure you will also leave Colombia with
great memories as I did just look around
you some of your fellow classmates will
become lifelong friends and will forever
remain a part of your Colombia family
and the networking opportunities here
with your professors classmates and
alumni are invaluable you will meet
people from all backgrounds and from all
walks of life in fact networking with
networking is a great way if not the
best way to help find a job after
graduation and to help advance your
career I can personally say that my
Columbia connections continue to have a
lasting and significant impact on my
life so here is my recommendation to all
future columbia alumni get actively
involved during your years as a Columbia
student it will help you define a
rewarding and memorable college
experience and your memories as a
student will help determine your
experiences as an alum after you
graduate now one of your memories I am
sure
we'll be singing the columbia university
alma mater Stan Columbia many many times
during the next four years sorry i'm not
going to sing it for you today however
our alma mater does remind me of a quote
by Archimedes painted on one of the
walls of the SW mud building it reads
give me a place to stand and I will move
the earth you have chosen to stand
Columbia you have chosen to come to
columbia to move the earth to help make
the world a better place we the members
of your Columbia family are counting on
you for outstanding leadership in the
best Columbia condition now speaking of
Columbia traditions I hope to see the
newest members of my Columbia family
throughout the year and many of the
social academic and cultural events
sponsored by the Columbia College and
Columbia engineering alumni associations
and of course I hope to see all of you
on homecoming day next month late in
October because this just might be the
year Columbia wins the Ivy League title
okay so like I would like now like to
introduce Fanny osky Pena Mora Dean of
Columbia University's through Foundation
School of Engineering and Applied
Science Dean Pena Mora is also the
Morris and alma Shapiro professor of
engineering at Columbia University and
he holds academic appointments as
professor of civil engineering and
engineering mechanics professor of earth
and environmental engineering and
professor of computer science he has
earned an international reputation for
his scholarship teaching research and
engineering innovations as well as
hands-on leadership in managing major
global engineering construction projects
before coming to columbia he served as
associate provost and the good skill
endowed professor in the department of
civil and environmental engineering at
the university of illinois at
urbana-champaign and he was previously
an associate professor in civil and
environmental engineering at some school
called MIT from which he received his
doctor of science degree in civil
engineering systems during his first
year as dean of the school dean pena
Mora has moved columbia forward with
positive momentum towards its goal of
becoming a top 10 engineering school and
he has created an enduring sense of
community on campus the Dean is truly
admired by alumni faculty and students
under his deanship Columbia engineering
continues to be a globally renowned
Center for interdisciplinary research as
well as the college of choice for those
who seek a superb technical and liberal
arts education within an exciting
urban setting for university please join
me now in welcoming Dean Pena ski Pena
Maura
thank you down for those words I'm happy
to join president Bollinger provo still
vice president Dirk's the Moody Adams
Dean chillin burger Alumni Association
president Chevelle Oh new Student
Orientation program coordinator Kevin
magus and members of the Columbia
University faculty in welcoming you
students of Columbia College and
Columbia engineering your parents family
and friends to today convocation
ceremonies as I greet you all and
particularly as I greet the Colombian
gineering class of 2014 for the first
time as a whole I see this moment as the
beginning of a four-year journey that
leads not only to your graduation in
2014 but to the celebration of the
school 150th anniversary we are
fortunate to have you here at this time
as part of a historic class and a
benchmark event in the history of the
school we will be planning exciting
celebrations of our sequence essential
and i look forward to walk to your
participation in the process and the
celebration as it is feeling for a
historic class you are impressive in
many ways and has said new admissions
records collectively you are among the
brightest the most socially responsible
and most artistically gifted high-school
students in the country and indeed the
world and these qualities
and these qualities apply equally to
those of you who are transfer students
or students of the combined plan you to
come to columbia engineering with most
impressive credentials having already
chained academically at other
institutions all of you engineering
students here today as you start your
journey at Columbia are following in the
tradition of the classes that have
preceded you and as such are becoming
part of an academic lineage that goes
back further than the funding of our
school indeed to the founding of
Columbia itself in 1754 from the very
beginning King's College as columbia was
known then was established to enlarge
the mind improve the understanding
polish the whole man and today of course
the whole woman and qualify them to
support the brightest characters of all
the elevated stations in life this
educational tradition in what we call
today the liberal arts but the unique
charge of King's College also was to
teach the arts of numbers and measuring
of surveying and navigation the
knowledge of various kinds of meteors
stones mines and minerals and everything
useful for the comfort the convenience
and the elegance of life so even before
our school became an independent entity
Columbia was an institution of and for
engineers among the early graduates
young Stevens of the class of 1768
stands out Stevens invented a technology
that made possible early steamboats and
locomotives he loved it for patent laws
in the early days of this country so
that his innovations could be protected
does it is often said that a concept of
intellectual property in the United
State has its roots at Columbia all the
great engineers leader follow including
the wit Clinton class of 1786 who
checked the history of New York City as
a major
and the history of New York State as a
governor he was a driving force behind
the construction of the Erie Canal
providing a water fruit to connect the
New York City to the middle of America a
strong America move as westward and
expanded a country geographically others
were responsible for an incredible
intellectual expansion in the fields of
engineering apply science and the pure
sciences with this explosive increase in
scientific knowledge can they need to a
specialization and our school was one of
the first of his kind in this country in
1864 Columbia founded the school of
mines with all the scientific
disciplines were contained within a
quarter century the new school was
turning out many of the country most
prominent engineering leaders one was
william barclay parson class of 1882 who
was responsible for building new york
city's first subway line the broadway
line with a stop light over here at 116
street but parsons influence was not
just felt locally he was among the first
colombian janiers to have a global
impact in 1898 he traveled to Shanghai
to become a primary surveyor and
designer of China's 1000 kilometres
railroad from Canton to Hong Kong he is
definitely an alias sample of a social
responsible column engineer leader
working global all the great engineers
and inventors from our school are
peppered throughout the country's
history all making advancement for the
comfort the convenience and the elegance
of life from Michael pooping the
developer of the transatlantic undersea
telegraphed a cable and his pupil Edwin
anstrom who revolutionary modern radio
communications in the early 20th century
to modern-day a loon I like King Albu
preceding of boeing commercial airlines
arming a vanishing a managing director
of goldman sachs also love burns CEO of
Xerox Vikram Pandit see of Citigroup and
our two most recent astronaut greg
johnson and mike maximum
by the way Mike maximino is the first
person to tweet from outer space all
this Colombian gineering alumni and
others like them have made their mark
not only in this world but in the case
of our astronauts on this world and
beyond just as our alumni will check by
the professors so we'll be you you will
be taught by faculty who are working on
some of the greatest challenges in
society for example in the broad area
sustainability that might be energy
climate or water you will work with
faculty such as professor Klaus Lackner
who is developing artificial trees that
will scrub carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere much the same way as 3l three
doors professor Alicia Park who is
working on an efficient cost-effective
energy conversion system that converts
non recyclable plastic into jet fuel
professor ponies are also musandam who
most recently is investigating the
effects of the BP oil spill in the
waters on the Gulf professor human chain
who is developing roofing materials that
double as solar panels and Patricia
professor Patricia Callahan who is a
summoning the effectiveness of green
groups to cool buildings and reduce or
mitigate storm runoff all these
professors and many more are working on
ways to better the human condition
whether through the investigation of
fundamental principles or the
application of those principles they are
part of the legacy of faculty excellent
has mark Columbia engineering from his
earliest years and is this faculty that
will support you students as you become
part of the Colombian gineering lineage
on that links to early Columbia and to
the Ivy League tradition that goes back
to colonial times as the newer member of
the Columbian family you will become the
next generation of Colombian gineering
and Applied Science leaders as you take
on greater responsibilities of
leadership in your profession working on
socially responsible projects to improve
the human condition you
impacting lives of future generations
early this month I hosted a meeting of
the Ivy League engineering dings and we
talked about what differentiates an
engineering education an Ivy League
institution from what is taught at other
institutions we agree that the
difference hinges on many factors among
them the strength of the academic
offerings outside of the engineering
disciplines the uniqueness of the cohort
of students who attend our situation and
the excellence of the faculty at
Columbia I call this educational
paradigm tie engineering and just so
there's no mistake this is the Greek
letter pi no apple pie think about the
Greek letter consider it as a cross
being supported by two columns
remembering a civil engineer so the
first supporting column of a pie
engineer is the depth of knowledge you
will gain in your engineering and
applied science major the second
supporting column is the knowledge that
you will gain from involved in research
experience entrepreneurship programs
community based service learning and
minors both technical and in the liberal
arts available throughout the school and
the college the overarching being
between the two supporting column is
Columbia's Fame core curriculum the
knowledge you gained in the humanities
that give you broader context to your
engineering and applied science
knowledge Columbia's core curriculum
stand out as the quiescent Quinn tential
way to provide all students with
wide-ranging perspectives on
transformative ideas in literature
philosophy history music art and science
with a core curriculum to provide a
context for your specialized knowledge I
know you will have a significant impact
on our future you will follow in the
footsteps of the gray alumna who have
gone before you and you will set the
footprints for the next generation of
socially responsible global engineering
and applied science leader whose work
results in the burning of the human
condition so I'm looking forward to
sharing these coming years with you
starting tomorrow morning at nine
am however meyer for your
orientation academic orientation I will
be there to greet you personally and to
make your first academic event at
Columbia engineering memorable it
promised to be excited thank you
now it is my pleasure to introduce the
Mitchell Mitchell moody add-ins ding of
Columbia College I am vice president for
undergraduate education you may say that
this convocation marks the start of our
sophomore year together at Columbia the
moody islands came here last you live
from Cornell but she was the Hutchinson
professor of philosophy director of the
program on ethics and public life and
vice provost for undergraduate education
I accomplished scholar she also taught
and Indiana University the University of
Rochester and Wellesley College she
holds a BA degree from both Wellesley
College and Australian averse city and
earned her MA and PhD in philosophy from
Harbor she has won numerous academic
honors including National Endowment for
the Humanities fellowship and a Marshall
scholarship please join me in welcoming
clean moody Alex
so good afternoon and welcome to all of
our new students incoming transfer
visiting students and combined plan
students and of course the class of 2014
we are so glad that you are finally here
as you've heard many times over the last
few months you are a very select group
of students and it's my pleasure to
congratulate you on the outstanding
accomplishment both inside and outside
the classroom that have brought you here
today I'm happy to be joined on stage by
several of the university's senior
academic leaders so president Bollinger
Provost steel Arts and Sciences vice
president Dirk's and Engineering and
Applied Sciences Dean Pena Maura their
presence here affirms the University's
commitment to undergraduate education
and to ensuring that Columbia is a
vibrant academic community in which even
our newest members can accomplish
remarkable things welcome also to the
families and perhaps especially to the
parents whose nurture and support have
been central to the success of the
students gathered here this afternoon I
suspect that right about now you are
having mixed feelings you're proud of
your children's achievements and you
understand that they need to find their
own way in this exciting new community
if they are to achieve even more and yet
at the same time it's so very hard to
leave but take comfort in the fact that
the student affairs professionals at
Columbia are just as committed as our
academic leaders are to the success of
your daughters and your sons over the
last 26 years I've been a professor and
academic administrator at institutions
large and small public and private small
town and urban and in that time I have
never worked with the more
dedicated accomplished and effective
group of colleagues than the student
affairs professionals here at Columbia
by all accounts your experience of our
move-in days has demonstrated this
dedication so I thank Dean Shallenberger
and his incredible staff for that and
for all that they do every day to make
this campus a safe and welcoming place
and to the continuing students like
Kevin Megos who have worked so hard to
make orientation exciting and helpful
thank you too for your commitment to
columbia now now members of the incoming
class I know that you are feeling your
own anxiety and uncertainty we hope that
our summer advising sessions your
Facebook networks and the efforts of
committed alumni like Daniel chevelle Oh
who's president of our engineering
alumni association will go at least some
way towards calming that first year
anxiety and uncertainty but I suspect
that nothing that happens before you
arrived on campus can entirely prevent
these feelings of course there's some
things of which you can be certain you
have joined an academic community that
offers a remarkable array of academic
programs taught by faculty scholars and
researchers working at the leading edge
of their disciplines if you're a
columbia college student you know that
you will choose from among more than 70
majors more than 30 concentrations in
the humanities the arts the social
sciences and the Natural Sciences the
menu of academic offerings includes
everything from long-standing majors
such as classics chemistry english and
italian to the newer kids on the block
like film studies Financial Economics
and sustainable development you also
know that prior to the academic
specialization that you do in a major or
concert
tration you will complete that
celebrated program in general education
that we call the Columbia College core
curriculum the core preserves the best
it preserves the best of the liberal
arts tradition it encourages active but
respectful disagreement and debate and
we hope it leads you to insightful and
imaginative thinking and genuinely
analytical and critical understanding of
course as I recite this extraordinary
menu of academic choices and as all of
you think about the possibilities that
these choices create for you you may
start to feel a little bit like the
character of Dorothy in The Wizard of Oz
when she realizes all at once that she's
not in Kansas anymore and indeed your
horizons are expanding in so many ways
you've spent at least four and perhaps
as many as twelve years planning for one
thing getting into a first-rate college
but now the boundaries of your choices
are expanding and this isn't just
because the academic and extracurricular
menu is getting bigger in college but
it's because your academic and personal
goals are becoming much more richly
textured and much more complex of course
some of you have come to columbia
knowing exactly what you want to major
in perhaps even knowing precisely where
you want to be five or even ten years
down the line but in a very short time
even you will realize that college opens
up many different paths by which you
might eventually get where you know you
want to be and the majority of our
incoming students expect the first few
years of college to help them decide
what to major in and help them figure
out where that major might lean if you
are in that majority you will be
anticipating the complexity of the
choices that lie ahead even more
intensely than students who come in
confident of the major they will choose
but none of you should let this
complexity overwhelm you instead start
thinking now about how to embrace the
best aspects of your uncertainty so that
you'll be able to keep your anxiety
about it within manageable bounds so for
instance when you are in class and you
feel that you do not understand
something or you're not quite sure why
your instructor or your fellow students
think that some idea is important don't
hesitate to say so as a professor I have
found that the students who get the
greatest benefit out of my classes and
who ultimately derived the most from
their college experience our students
who are not afraid to acknowledge and
express their uncertainty it takes a lot
of courage of course to embrace
uncertainty in this way it takes courage
whether you do so in a relatively public
setting of a classroom discussion or if
you do it in an individual meeting with
an instructor or an advisor but if you
embrace uncertainty in the right way you
will be on the right path to taming it
in my classes students who have admitted
their uncertainty are often voicing the
very same uncertainty that's felt by
their peers and even when they speak
primarily for themselves their comments
often provide the opportunity to clarify
concepts or problems of value to the
class as a whole I suggested earlier
that even the outwardly most
sophisticated and self-confident student
coming to a place like Columbia can
sometimes feel a little bit like Dorothy
in The Wizard of Oz but recall that in
that story Dorothy eventually realizes
that it's possible to find Wonder in her
everyday surroundings the value of this
insight transcends the story it
transcends generational differences it
transcends cultural difference and it
has shaped human experience and culture
in the most extraordinary
ways when we embrace uncertainty we will
find that surprise and astonishment may
await us in even the most ordinary and
familiar contexts poets and philosophers
have celebrated wonder as an essential
component of great poetry and drama
theologians recognize that wonder is
often the source of religious insight
and thinkers of all kinds understand
that wonder is the origin of
groundbreaking discovery and science and
indeed in virtually every field of human
inquiry so this suggests that one of the
most important thing you as a student
can do is to remain open to the
possibility of being surprised surprised
by what you will do and learn here at
Columbia and by the people with whom you
will share this Columbia experience
whether in the classroom and laboratory
on the athletic field or in a Night at
the Opera over pizza or pad thai in your
residence hall remain open to the
possibility that you will be surprised
by and astonished by some wonderful but
unexpected insight of course this world
can be hostile to wonder when political
debates celebrate smugness and
self-righteousness they may thereby lead
young people to cynicism and apathy when
secondary school experiences leave
students feeling fatigued and overworked
they may become jaded by this sometimes
mindless pursuit of credentials and
numbed by constant testing that
undermines academic excitement but the
students who are in front of us here
today are here because their application
suggested that they are special students
you are special your application
suggested to us that your academic
achievements in high school grew out of
genuine interest and that your
extracurricular activities embodied
serious commitment as you embark on your
Columbia careers
resolve now to do everything you can to
prove that we were right embrace
uncertainty and remain open to surprise
and Wonder and I promise that your time
at Columbia will turn out to be some of
the best years of your lives thank you
oh cool in there okay it's now my
pleasure to introduce Columbia
University President Lee Bollinger
president Bollinger is a truly visionary
academic leader he is also a widely
cited scholar of the first amendment
with the special focus on freedom of
speech and freedom of the press he is a
director of the federal reserve bank of
new york of the washington post company
a member of the Pulitzer Prize board and
a fellow of the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences before becoming president
at Columbia he was president at the
University of Michigan at Ann Arbor
where he also served as a law professor
and dean of the law school he is a
graduate of the University of Oregon and
he earned his law degree right here at
our own Columbia Law School he clerked
for judge Wilfred Feinberg on the US
Court of Appeals and for former United
States Supreme Court Chief Justice
Warren Berger so please join me in
welcoming president Bollinger to the
podium
thank you thank you very much just have
a very few things to say to the new
students but before that let me just say
welcome to the parents and the families
who are here especially the parents for
those of us who have had children and
sent them to college and sent them to
Columbia we know that this is a very
poignant moment so for the students a
few simple things to say to you this
afternoon which I've condensed in
recognition of how busy the time this is
for you as well as how the wildering the
first thing is about you and this period
of life that you're entering it's a
simple message again but very profound
and one you will hear from every
direction perhaps especially from your
parents it is this this will be a time
in your lives that will be unlike any
other it is in fact one you will always
be trying to recreate for yourself
because in a way it's impossible fully
to appreciate until you don't have it
anymore never again will you have the
full array of human knowledge at your
beck and call with the most
knowledgeable people in the world
standing ready and eager to be your
guides and at a time when you can be
single-minded about learning and when
you have the energy to engage fully in
the process of discovery I am confident
as they're all the faculty here that it
will be for you the most thrilling of
adventures again and again you will have
the memorable experiences of realizing
just how rich and complex human
understanding is you will stare blankly
at a great painting
or a great poem wondering what it's all
about and then gradually layer after
layer of meaning will unfold before you
or you will be asked to think more
deeply and critically then you have
about something you have believed in for
perhaps all your life or have just taken
for granted as being right and true and
then you will be stunned by your own
incapacity to defend that belief and
unsettled by the persuasiveness of other
perspectives you had not heretofore
imagined and now you must contend with
and over time and with the repetition of
these encounters with your own ignorance
which turns out to be a normal condition
of a thoughtful existence you will come
to feel relaxed in a state of humility
and exhilarated by acquiring the powers
of imagination to appreciate human
genius and the magnificence of the
natural world the power of thought will
become your best friend this is why all
of us here today feel a sense of envy at
what you are embarking on for us it's
not been there done that it's been there
and would do it again in a heartbeat
next I want to say just a little about
the times in which you are coming to
college college is such a defining part
of our lives that we naturally look at
what is going on in the world outside
and incorporate that into our own
identities if you would just give a
nickel to Columbia and I really hope you
will for every time over the rest of
your life that you say when I was a
student at Columbia
and then recount some major historical
event each of you will endow a
scholarship for your successors we know
that things will happen while you are
here that we cannot now predict and they
will have an impact on how we think and
maybe they will have an impact on the
way in which you conduct your lives but
besides the unpredictable we can already
see that you are going to college when
truly major and historically
unprecedented forces are at work
reshaping our world you arrived at
Columbia when the nation is engaged in
two wars when sixteen percent of the
labor force of America is unemployed
when the greatest economic revolution in
human history is transforming the lives
of billions of people yet right now the
global economy is experiencing the most
severe stress since the Great Depression
eighty years ago when the vulnerability
of the natural environment and of
species is at its height when our own
political culture seems unduly
fragmented and disturbingly unable to
find common ground and when principles
we have come to regard as integral and
fundamental to a good society like
freedom of speech and press two things I
care about are being challenged and
threatened on the new global stage and
now we must argue for them all over
again all these and so many more
momentous issues will be will have to be
sorted out and it is you quite frankly
like your earliest predecessors John Jay
and Alexander Hamilton who will have to
do the sorting which brings me finally
to Columbia your University
here is another simple truth if you're a
person who is interested in exploring
the greatest achievements of the human
mind in really immersing yourself in
their works and if you're a person who
is also interested in being an explorer
in the world at the moment of its
creation then Columbia is the place the
best place on the planet to do those
things this university is incomparable
in its respect for the intellectual and
artistic heritage of humankind across
all civilizations and in its daring to
confront and to be part of the world as
it is and as it might be so on behalf of
all of us the trustees administration
the faculty staff it is an enormous
pleasure to be with you as you embark in
this special and unique venture in your
lives at this time in world history and
at this great great University
congratulations and good luck
Thank You president Bollinger at this
time I'd like to introduce students
representing Columbia's various acapella
performance groups who will lead us in
singing Columbia University's fight song
roar lion roar you'll find the lyrics in
your program so i encourage you to sing
along we ask that you remain in your
seats until the academic recessional is
completed again welcome